first person zombie brawler dying like
is full of cars burnt out abandoned
husks of cars that are perfect for
parkouring over but not so great for
driving the following dlc on the other
hand weaves customizable dirt buggies
into its basic structure trading dense
urban slums for sweeping open farmland
it's a pretty unexpected change but the
following works well delivering a
sizeable chunk of story-driven content
that feels at once distinct from and in
sync with the original experience the
setup is Swift and simple a short time
after the conclusion of the full game a
mysterious outsider shows up in zombie
infested her ran ranting feverishly
about a place where everyone's immune to
the outbreak gruff protagonist /
cardboard cutout Kyle crane uses the
man's map to find his way out of the
city and into a creepy mystery centered
on a secretive cult crane still lacks
depth but the following delivers fresh
themes that set it apart from well every
other zombie apocalypse tale out there
it's self-contained story while slow to
start gradually becomes an engaging
conspiracy thriller complete with
tension intrigue and a few genuinely
surprising twists it's both more
original and more satisfying than the
full game's narrative of course because
no one's ever willing to divulge
information for free you're once again
stuck doing favors to earn trust which
means more errands and fetch quests
fortunately missions are generally less
of a grind here not only because of the
strong narrative framing but also
because you've got more gameplay options
to work with the game doesn't contrived
some reason to strip away all your stuff
and boot you back to square one
thankfully so when you walk out of here
and at the start of the following all
your skills and gear come with you this
means less desperate leveling early on
and more confident exploration you will
end up relying more on firearms though
simply because it's safer in the
coverless countryside but this allows
you to appreciate a side of dying lights
generally male a focused combat that was
previously underutilized you're battling
the same zombies but with the new
environment come all new strategies
there's also an added skill tree to
level up one devoted to your deadly new
ride well series of rides like dying
lights weapons buggies breakdown with
use and need to be repaired and upgraded
forcing you to scavenge for parts and
gas to keep them running because it's so
closely mirrors the established crafting
system though
feels like a perfectly natural evolution
of an existing mechanic it also creates
a strong sense of ownership and reward
as you unlock new skills and gather new
upgrades eventually equipping arrived
with things like clean throwers UV
headlights and deployable minds you can
see the impact in-game and know that
your hard work has paid off as in the
main game early weakness makes later
strength feel earned and therefore super
gratifying more importantly driving
around is just flat-out fun the basic
driving controls function beautifully
leaving you to focus on plowing through
zombies and a number of scenic locales
like rocky coastlines and endless grassy
fields the new map is actually larger
than the original though it's far less
crowded with climbable objects you'll
still have plenty of opportunities to
flex your parkour muscles
but again the clear focus here is mad
max-style buggy driving the following
even provides optional races both time
trial events and head-to-head sprints
for up to four players online that
provide a welcome diversion from dying
lights central gameplay the following
isn't flawless though in addition to
cardboard crane and some mundane quests
I also occasionally encountered enemies
who couldn't figure out how to walk
around minor obstacles more than once i
respawned seemingly in the middle of
nowhere which left me without a buggy on
a map built for commuting and prevalent
boss level zombies made flying solo
pretty tough especially since the big
guys were able to absorb basically every
bullet I had
still rather than giving players more of
the same the following evolves dying
lights formula by adding substantial
noob mechanics that compliment or even
reframe familiar gameplay elements the
dirt buggies fit right in and provide
both rewarding survivor strategy and
moment-to-moment thrills the amount of
content is impressive for an expansion
with probably ten hours of missions and
plenty more for completionists I guess
you could say it's a lot to sink your
teeth into because it's a zombie game
zombies
you